hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey there's this trailer out
ad astra official trailer Brad Pitt
space movie
apparently it's dropped while we were
out watching Fox's other new hit Dark
Phoenix last night we just shot our
review and then as I was gathering
footage to edit for the review I was
like oh totally miss this trailer
different space adventure to go on let's
go check it out right away what are you
thinking about
they have Tyler Armageddon today here's
a kid gave His life and pursuit of
knowledge that's Tommy Lee Jones oh God
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere
plane crashes they're calling it the
search made here we have some highly
classified information looking into us
about the Lima project its objective was
to search for advanced extraterrestrial
life
okay and ship disappeared approximately
16 years into the mission and the
commander was 16 members this might come
as quite a shock to you the problems
experimenting with a highly classified
material that could threaten our entire
solar system all life would be destroyed
we're counting on you to find out what's
happening most popular item please
describe yes I'm feeling good ready to
do my job to the best of my abilities
I remain fully committed to the lawful
completion of the mission if necessary I
will destroy the project and it's into
hiding
that hell is going on
[Music]
they have a job to do are you ready all
right
[Music]
damn another space movie with a male
lead who seems kind of stuff go out
someplace very remote and either find
somebody or something and bring back
that Intel it seems like you had a
little more emotion than Neil Armstrong
at first man yeah yeah but not quite as
much as a McConaughey and interstellar
you know that look shot great yeah that
looks from the DPO works with Nolan now
tomorrow I think on interstellar
specifically actually to man that look
terrifying at times yeah verify yeah
face movies freak me out anyway but yeah
especially I mean when that whole column
of spires is blowing up and you got the
astronauts flying off they love those
movies yeah I get vibes of like gravity
meets interstellar exactly with Liv
Tyler reprising her role that she had an
Armageddon as loyal girlfriend slash
wife two hot male lead and Tommy Lee
Jones reprising his role from space
cowboys yeah Brad Pitt's gonna catch
space and mention halfway through I mean
Brad Pitt's gonna have a hell of a year
huh
that's huge what's the point of time in
Hollywood it's I feel like we don't
really get much Brad Pitt lately no we
ain't fitting and then we O's gonna do
the same thing he's gonna just start
doubling up on movies yeah take a break
and then you come back with a whole
buncha stuff well this looks like a cool
sci-fi film man looking out looking for
his father
I'm sure help unite with Ben out into
this movie now time with a Joe just
showed up to take photos I'll make a few
hundred dollars for your movie fact I'll
just send you some pictures I already
had I'm curious to see where it goes by
the end of this because it looks like
it's gonna get crazier like a full-on
space battle look the other shooting at
each other
well that's I don't know that's gonna be
too much but it looked cool it looked
the only aspect of this trailer that
really left me sort of like what
is happening cuz like the the rest of it
looks like a space Discovery drama and
then you know that part to me was like
oh is this gonna have like an
action-movie turn cuz like the the movie
at least looks like it's gonna be a kind
of solitaire from at least the story
they're pitching me yeah him going out
into space to find his father after so
many years 16 yeah a long time that's a
in space even though I know time in
space works different might be one of
those interstellar wormhole things where
I've been gone first 20 minutes
something like that get a da Jones cut
out for you I'm gonna say this right now
the person's reaction you should be
watching as my brothers get chappies he
is obsessed with space and all these
things like when I had him on our
interstellar trailer reaction years ago
I was freaking bizarre and I I'm sure he
covered this already and I'm sure that
he had like a lot of cool insight to
bring into it for us were more like oh
this looks harrowing and the isolation
situation it is are they dealing with
some kind of potential stem situation
some kind of a I think going on
I really wonder because they have that
whole moment where they say you know
your father's experimenting with this
unstable element thing that that could
destroy the entire universe or at least
our galaxy yeah and I don't know really
what that is I don't know did you get
like a strong evil how kind of a little
bit yeah that's the thing is I'm having
trouble pinpointing like the central I
don't know conflict or antagonizing
force other than distance anytime
there's a space thing and then there's
red lighting I just assume it's that
computers doing so and there seems to be
an emotional core with this movie you
know he's got his woman back home Liv
Tyler and then
he hasn't seen his dad in a long time he
says he does what he does because of his
father who was a legendary astronaut now
he's gonna go search for him I'm hoping
that this movie really utilizes these
emotional course setups that they're
having here because sometimes in certain
movies like this it can feel a little
bit you know tacked on to try to make us
care and not really be in tune with the
arc without ruining some thing in first
man if you haven't seen it I thought
they did a great job at making it
ultimately a character driven emotional
arc by the time he gets to the moon and
something that occurs there and I'm
hoping we get that you know like it's
easy for movies like this to get a
little bit concerned over consumed with
visuals which look great and ideas which
I'm sure will be awesome I just I want
that level to be there because it's Brad
Pitt and Brad Pitt is an incredible
actor and also a core giuse human being
man is he age 95 yeah in the blood of
birds like you know when you get a guy
like him in this kind of role I want an
emotional piece from this because you
got like even Donald Sutherland in here
as well who's in her first split second
and you know I feel like one thing
people might not be toning it no I'm
covering this trailer might not be the
characters the acting because it's cool
space movie but that's something I
really care about and I really wanted to
excel here with this kind of cast - yeah
well with this kind of movie - that
looks like it wants to have a lot of big
ideas on its mind and at least from you
know looking up the log line on IMDB it
seems like this is at least trying to
reach out pretty far into the cerebral
realm of like the nature of the
existence of humanity and stuff like
that and those are big ideas that I love
to see movies at least attempt you know
stuff like interstellar and even if it
doesn't come together always
you know there's usually something to
appreciate and so from this movie that's
kind of what I'm hoping for is some kind
of interesting poetic idea the thing is
I I did get a lot of kind of
great information from this trailer so
I'm like is there an alien thing going
on is this some kind of weird molecular
thing he's like it's an AI it seems like
it's more alien than AI yeah yeah and I
mean because there's that whole thing
about like researching extraterrestrial
life and things that was the original
mission I think yeah yeah and I'm like
is that gonna play into yeah new mission
somehow but I don't know it looks
definitely fascinating and it looks
pretty beautiful to look at the only the
only big question was at the front did
Brad Pitt like literally fall off that
thing back to earth yeah like he landed
right now Sandra Bullock fell off that
thing wouldn't you get destroyed on a
man tree but but comment below if you
know how space works yeah alright guys
well if you like this video please hit
that like button you guys can subscribe
to the real rejects tell us what you
think about this trailer in the comments
below
because engagement engagement helps
everything engagement argue with each
other about the rules of space and last
but not least let's give a patron of the
day shadow I want to shout out Curt
Anderson on this one Curt last time we
shouted you out we mentioned how you
were you know because you're the nomad
you're the guy who's always traveling
the world and you think you found a
place to settle down you know where you
have not traveled to beyond this world
space the final frontier
you can't just settle down man you if
everyone at our patreon page is gonna be
the one who helps discover a new planet
for us to colonize on with you know
everything going on on this planet right
now being all messed up dude
you're the guy you already love
travelling you already like getting out
of here you might as well just find a
way to get to space you're the one dude
who can make it work and plus it's got
an Instagram
look like you could be some like famous
astronaut man you should do it go to
space and bring us back a moon rock or
something but don't you know do
something messed up that's gonna destroy
I'll impregnate an alien ship oh that
would be fun